alors le nouveau james bond est arrivé
son nom c'est timothy dalton
son film c'est tuer n'est pas jouer est
la première de ce film a eu lieu à
londres lundi soir je vous propose de
voir quelques images de cette
manifestation
alors vous allez reconnaître des
personnalités que vous connaissez très
bien
son altesse royale les dida le prince
charles la cbat moselle dabo c'est la
partenaire de timothy que voici
le film a été donc présenté à londres
voici quand même des extraits de des
grands anciens vous avez reconnu la sean
connery roger moore il était normal que
l'on salue les aînés je vous propose de
retrouver timothy bonjour timothy alors
en quoi êtes-vous différent des autres
james bond ou à la gang à écouter je
crois que c'est un petit peu difficile
de faire des comparaisons entre moi et
les autres james bond il ya les
différences bien sûr mais chante
qu'andris héros du roman tous les deux
ont réussi à incarner le rôle comme il
l'entendait c'est certain qu'ils étaient
très différents l'un de l'autre ils ont
tous les deux très bien réussi dans ce
rôle
mon interprétation du rôle est un peu
différente aussi bien de gens john rich
de rogers mort juste mais je me sens
mais pour moi en ligue 1 que la seule
façon de travailler avec ce rôle c'était
de retourner au livre de ian fleming
pouvoir qu'elle était vraiment le
personnage créé par ian fleming ciboure
voit vraiment que quelqu'un a donné
naissance à toute cette série de films
et je trouve comprend qu'il ya
énormément de qualité dans le personnage
de fleming j'ai des goûts hier que nous
avons découvert le personnage était très
humain non c'était n'était pas un
superman n'étaient pas un personnage de
blasons de dimension et c'était un homme
très humain cadet des émotions souffrait
il se battait il s'en sortait toujours
bien sûr parce qu'il a fait sa qualité
très spéciales ne sont pas un extrait de
film maintenant parce qu'il a sauté une
réponse courage mais c'est un homme très
humain
alors vous avez sûrement remarqué que le
temps de latence et bien c'est tout
simplement le temps que timothy bien on
lui traduisent la question que je lui
pose à lui parlé de la sensibilité
voyons donc à un extrait de ce film